meet kevin is very very passionate i'll
give him that he's very passionate
he wants california to succeed he wants
california to be better
but um he's an ideologue and this is
honestly a problem i have
with most people on the quote unquote
left today they uh
they think their good intentions
supersede their bad ideas
right so the idea of what we're gonna do
is we're going to
friendly put in sending the national
guard to
kindly round up uh the
yeah the unwanted people on our streets
and we're going to put them in these
awesome super not re-education detention
camps where they're going to get the
education that they need and the help
that they need and we're just gonna you
know
because listen man if people that were
in this situation
were capable of functioning at that sort
of level now i'm not saying that
it's not a noble idea what i'm saying is
is that
rounding up the people you don't want
and putting them into a camp
has been tried before and it didn't work
out yeah so
is that the only thing you took from his
two-hour sit down here no like that one
thing or what else
would i no because he also wants to put
uh local governments under occupation as
well so it was all negative stuff there
was nothing you agreed with it was all
just ideologue that i don't agree with i
think that what happens is that listen
if you were going to sit here and have a
conversation
today what is the story what happened
over the weekend
after the show you want to have a
conversation with me about the way you
think
things should be and you want to be you
know uh some sort of a utopian ideologue
that's fine that's your that's your
prerogative as as a person okay i wish
we can do x
if you're running for governor of the
fourth largest economy in the freaking
world
and your idea is to send in the national
guard and round up the people i don't
want on my streets
i'm sorry but you have to have some
pushback and it should have frankly
it's not about him there should have
been somebody in his camp that was like
okay you understand how this is going to
sound to anybody
that believes in in the cobra paradox at
all like in
promise i don't even know if he has a
camp i think he's like kind of doing it
solo
guys this is not like a kid you're gonna
like high five like you're doing great
speaking on stages
of california you had strong opinions on
him too
i think that was the problem and most
importantly
he's the type that probably has done
very well
rehearsed but when he comes into maybe
like a road game
hostile situation and really wasn't even
hostile which i give him credit for
right in fairness but to me that's an
opportunity right and i think he missed
it because
he did get pushed back and
kind of deflected a lot and couldn't get
to the point and i think
one of the things that i've noticed like
here when we talk about politics or
business
is a running mate people the
partnerships that he has
this guy has a ton of things going on
you know in his life but he didn't once
mention like
who would help put these people in these
places
that requires a lot of funding a lot of
money he didn't walk us through those
things
and that's what i was most concerned
with and then when pat would ask
about that it was more like well i don't
have all the answers but then he had all
the answers
i have all the answers and i don't
really i need the data
so that's where i got kind of confused
as to okay you're a know-it-all but you
don't know anything here's what i will
tell you about this here's what i would
tell you about this
roger stone okay people ask me and say
why do you interview all these random
people you know like all these mobsters
roger stone former criminals all these
people right because everything's about
how did it get you to
be thinking the way you think right
roger stone is a pretty
pretty weird guy and when he was talking
he said a few different things he said
in life everybody goes through three
phases he says first phase is
who is roger stone like meaning who's
roger stone
second phase is get me roger stone
third phase is i need somebody like
roger stone fourth phase is
who's roger stone meaning you're
forgotten about right you start off with
you're for
nobody knows who you are irrelevant then
you go to dude this guy's amazing i want
him then you go to get me somebody like
him that's younger
then you go to i have no i've never
heard of him before right okay
i don't care what anybody says agree or
disagree with this guy the level of
respect i got for
people like me kevin you go build a 2
million subscriber channel at 28 29
years old and get that kind of an
audience in money real estate
making 6.2 million dollars in a year at
that age
he's absolutely crushing it this is the
biggest thing with a guy like that
i've been running sales teams for a long
time the biggest thing with a guy like
that
at that point sometimes when you win
very early
one of the hardest things for you to do
is to listen to anybody
it's the hardest thing to do when you
win early when you win
later after you've lost anything
everything it's one of the best things
that have happened to you
it typically ends up becoming a better
person to be a leader
when you lost everything in your 20s i'm
talking
girl money fame success you were the
main guy you got your
nose bloody all of that 20s and 30s when
it happens
then you lead in your 40s and 50s now
you're kind of like remember listen you
know
everybody gets knocked out hey listen
yeah as bad as you are everybody go
so i think he hasn't gone through that
yet which is my recommendation too was
to go get
his nose bloody and then the other part
is you need a couple guys like them
behind closed doors
yeah you need a couple guys like them to
talk to behind closer that's going to be
like yeah i don't know about that i
don't know it's going to work
push back push back push back and then
for him to argue with you and say no
here's why i believe in this
and he's still going to push back and
he's going to say you know what no i get
the point
kind of like yesterday watching the you
know at the house and you see there's
pushback
and then finally he's like yeah okay i
agree that's fine i totally understand i
think there needs to be a little bit of
that
we're going to see what's going to
happen with him i i hope the guy's got a
big upset he doesn't slow down and i
hope this doesn't discourage him to go
run
right but uh it is what it is let me get
you guys opinion on something because
you know right after the podcast who's
on ricky with you guys
yes and you popped in oh no that was the
one time
so right after the podcast i interviewed
him yeah and it was more of a financial
type interview wasn't that i even said
we're not going to be political all we
talk is money all we talk is money
we did the financial interview but i
said let me ask you something kevin
respect you came on
you know you did your thing
have you ever been a a mayor
a representative a dog catcher like if
you've never been in politics
ever what makes you think a lack of
experience is a good thing meaning
you've done real estate for 10 years
i've never done real estate i've done
finance
yeah but i've never done real estate
that's like me saying i think i'm gonna
be a realtor today and the number one
realtor in the entire state
what makes you think that you can just
be governor with
zero experience and i think this is what
i would have called the dj
djt effect donald j trump is that
look he became president with zero
experience but the guy's been in the
media
the guy's been in yeah for 40 years he's
been in the political game
but my point is this trump made it
acceptable for anyone to say all right
[ __ ] it i'm giving it a shot
whatever it may be whereas i think like
pat said respect to getting out there
and think you could do your thing but if
you have zero experience i can't believe
i'm going to say this but
adam that's a good point um
it happens more often but yeah let that
go through your head a little bit anyway
johnny cash yeah but you got to cut that
short clip
to your just cut that out for me to your
credit man and your point the whole time
he was sitting there and i actually said
it
later on the interview because i didn't
want to hammer the guy but i have been
in politics and i was i wasn't in
on the other side of it i don't know you
you literally wrote speeches for chris
christie
yes yes so now they do thank you for
that yeah but the
yeah but the the the side i'm trying to
say
is is that the whole time and i waited
two hours and then he finally went on
the offensive and i actually pointed
that to him i was like congratulations
you finally went on the offensive yeah
and i texted pat afterwards because you
were talking about giving you know he
he needs a little he needs encouragement
and he does have a bright future and i
said well if he if he's going to do this
and he he's going to make drastic
changes like that he has to make it
about the opponent
so anytime anybody if you're ever
thinking about running for politics you
get this one for free
this is the value entertainment all
right all he had to do
at any moment and he still didn't do it
in in the video that he did
in response he had to admit that what he
was saying
was outrageous but these are outrageous
times there you go that's all he had to
do
he had to say listen i don't want to put
california under occupation
but it's a state of emergency gavin
newsom screwed up
so bad for so long that we have to treat
this
as the emergency that it is take it off
of him put it on gavin newsom
treat it as something that's temporary
in a response to
bad administration that he has to come
and i don't want to do this
i don't want to do this now you have
libertarians like me republicans like
other people saying this is an overreach
of government but at least it's
temporary and at least he
he knows that it's bad now it could be
bs everything that the government does
that's temporary
the the federal income tax was temporary
measure 100 years later we're still here
right
so we all know that in the back of our
head and that's why we give pushback we
know that you're taking this power and
you're never giving it back
now the other side who wants to hear the
utopian butterflies and the hell yeah
we're gonna we're gonna heal all the
homeless we're
they've been trying to do it for 10 000
years but i got this plan and this plan
is we're going to round them up and
throw them somewhere else where you
don't see them
dude now the wild thing the craziest
part about this was rudy giuliani in the
sit-down that you had with him literally
said
the first thing you have to do is clean
up the streets you have to get rid of
the homeless it's the very first thing
rudy said
he said you can you can lower in the
interview with you he said you can
lower murders by 90 but nobody ever sees
a murder so they won't believe crime is
going down
unless you get rid of the graffiti and
you clean up the homeless he said until
i got rid of the squeegee guys
nobody believed new york had a
turnaround right so in that time
he's he his methodology isn't
necessarily wrong
his messaging really really is and and
that's where it's great feedback for him
that's great feedback and by the way
knowing him he's probably listening
someone's going to tell him about this
he's going to listen to this
and hopefully he'll take that feedback
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye